hey guys welcome to another cooking
video today is National Cherry Pie day
so that can give you a really great hint
of what we're gonna make today this is
going to be a no recipe recipe I'm just
gonna make it I mean how hard can a
cherry pie be you put some cherry in pie
and you cook it step one go to the
grocery store step two find some
cherries in a can step 3 find yourself
some pie crusts all right just get your
little pie crust open it all up what we
like to call I am freakin lazy you could
use real cherries but why would we do
that when we have a bright here fresh
pea in a can and this one you need a can
opener you just prepare your blender to
people ending look at this
take your cherries and put them in the
blender blend the cherries stop draw
open up shop this is a blended cherry
pie get on my level some people may want
some whole cherries in their pie if
you're one of those people feel free to
add two whole cherries let's lit up pie
shop whoa there's all rah rah rah
I'm filling in your pie this is a really
difficult process so please pay very
close attention so you guys don't screw
it up don't worry commando forgot about
our wonderful cherry puree just take
this and just dump it right in to the
center look how beautiful this is it's
like a cherry soup think I'm a little
too much in you're not going to put too
much of your cherry puree just get
yourself a scoop scoop it out I'm just
gonna mix that around real nice and I
think it looks like our pie is done now
for this pie I chose not to put a top
crust on it mostly because I'm super
lazy and I didn't want to have to make
any crust oh I love me putting on it is
this we're almost preheated but I mean
what did I do is perfect go up another
big right it's the time to put the
cherry pie into the oven like so hold on
I put the GoPro down oh my gosh it is
spilling everywhere looks great looks
great now we put it into the oven for
another school's amount of time which
I'm going to guess about 25 minutes and
when we return I'm feeling what we have
is going to just be a hot freaking mess
we'll find out
okay guys it's time to get it out of the
oven there we go
time to get the fire out of the oven
it's not hot
what do you think it is done you can't
just buy liquid in the pie crust called
time okay time for the whipped cream
it's gonna melt all oops
okay oh look at that guys this looks
like it might actually be good except
what oh how do I get this out I get some
crust come here try it you know why I
want all that here it is okay just take
a little bite come here mmm mmm
well guys don't you're watching I hope
that you enjoyed look at that let me
know what you guys would like to see me
cook next you have any other suggestions
leave them in the comments below don't
forget to subscribe make sure you like
this video if you did like it if you
didn't like it you could like it anyway
I won't tell anybody
Qi later